The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Any questions from
last time about Gibbs Sampling?
No?
So at the end, we
introduced this concept
of relative entropy.
So I just wanted to briefly
review this, and make
sure it's clear to everyone.
So the relative
entropy is a measure
of distance between
probability distributions--
can be written different ways,
often with this D p q notation.
And as you'll see, it's
the mean bit-score,
if you're scoring a motif
with a foreground model, pk,
and a background model,
qk it's the average log
odd score under the motif model.
And I asked you to show
that under the special case
where qk is 1 over
4 to the w, that
is uniform background, that the
relative entropy of the motif
ends up being simply 2w minus 8.
Did anyone have a
chance to do this?
It's pretty simple--
has anyone done this?
Can anyone show this?
Want me to do it briefly?
How many would like to
actually see this derivation?
It's very, very quick.
Few people, OK.
So I'll just do
that really quick.
So summation Pk log Pk over
qk equals-- so you rewrite it
as a difference, the
log of a quotient
is the difference of the log.
Of summation log Pk plus
summation Pk log qk.
OK, and then the special case
that we're dealing with here
is that qk is
equal to a quarter,
if we're dealing
with the simplest
case of a one-base motif.
And so you recognize that
that's minus H of Pp, right?
H of p is defined as minus
that, so it's minus H p.
And this here, that's
just a quarter.
Log 2 of a quarter is minus 2.
You can take the minus
2 outside of the sum,
so you're ending up with
minus 2-- I'm sorry.
How come Sally
didn't correct me?
Usually she catches
these things.
So that's a minus there,
right, because we're
taking the difference.
And so then we have a minus
2 that we're pulling out
from this, and you're
left with summation Pk.
And summation Pk, it sums to 1.
So that's just 1.
And so this equals minus
minus 2, or 2 minus H of p.
And there are many other
results of this type that
can be shown in
information theory.
Often there are
some simple results
you can get simply by
using this by splitting it
into different
terms, and summing.
So another result that
I mentioned earlier,
without showing, is that if you
have a motif, say, of length 2,
that the information
content of that motif model
can be broken into
the information
content of each position
if your model is such
that the positions
are independent.
So you would have,
in that case--
let's just take the entropy of
a model on [? dinucleotides. ?]
It that would be minus
summation Pi Pj log Pi Pj,
if you have a model where
the two are independent,
and this sum would be
taken over both i and j.
And so if you want to show
that this is equal to-- I
claim that this is
equal to the i--
Anyway, if you have different
positions, in general--
this would be the more general
term-- where you have two
different compositions at the
two positions for the motif.
And then you can show that
it's equal to basically the sum
the entropies at
the two positions.
OK, you do the same thing.
You separate out
the log of the sum,
in terms of the sum of
the logs, and then you
do properties of summations
until you get the answer.
OK, so this is your
homework, and obviously it
won't be graded.
But we'll check in
next Thursday and see
if anyone has
questions with that.
So what is the use
of relative entropy?
the main use in
bio-informatics is
that it's a measure that
takes into account non-uniform
backgrounds.
The standard definition
of information
basically works
when the background
is uniform, but falls apart
when it's non-uniform.
So if you have a
very biased genome,
like this one shown
here which is 75% A T,
then the information content
using the standard method
would be two bits of this
motif, which is P C equals 1.
But then, that would
predict, using the formula,
that a motif occurs 2 to
the information content--
once every 2 to the information
content bases-- that
would be 2 to the 2,
which would be 4 bases,
and that's clearly
incorrect in this case.
But the relative
entropy, if you do it,
there will be four terms, but
three of them just have a 0.
And then one of them has a 1,
so it's 1 times log 1 over 1/8,
in this case, and that's
will be equal to 3.
And so the relative
entropy clearly
gives you a more
sensible version.
It's a good measure for
non-uniform backgrounds.
Questions about
relative entropy?
All right, so then
we said you can
use a weight matrix, or a
position-specific probability
matrix, for a motif like this
five-prime splice site motif,
assuming independence
between positions.
But if that's not true, then
a natural generalization
would be an inhomogeneous
Markov model.
So now, we're going to say
that the base at position k
depends on the base
at position k minus 1,
but not on anything before that.
And so, the probability
of generating
a particular sequence, S1 to S9,
is now given by this expression
here, where you have for
every base after the first,
you have a conditional
probability.
This is the
conditional probability
of seeing the base, S2,
at position minus 2, given
that you saw S1 at position
minus 3, and so forth.
And again, you can take the log
for convenience, if you like.
So I actually implemented
both of these models.
So just for thinking about it,
if you want to implement this,
you have parameters-- these
conditional probability
parameters-- and you
estimate them as shown here.
So remember, conditional
probability of A given B
is the joint probability
divided by the probability of B.
And so in this case, that
would be the joint probability
of seeing C A at minus
3, minus 2, divided
by the probability of
seeing C at minus 3.
You could have the ratio of the
frequencies, or, in this case,
the counts, because the
normalization constant
will cancel.
Is that clear?
So I actually implemented
both the weight matrix model
and a first-order Markov model
of five-prime splice sites,
and scored some
genomic sequence.
And what you can see here, the
units are in 1/10th-bit units,
is that they both are partially
successful in separating real
five-prime splice sites-- shown
in black from the background,
shown in light bars--
but in both cases,
it's not a perfect separation.
There's some overlap here.
And if you zoom
there, you can see
that the Markov model
is a little bit better.
It has a tighter
tail on the left.
So it's generally
separating the true
from the decoys a
little bit better.
Not dramatically better,
but slightly better.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: From the
previous slide,
could you clarify what the
letter R and the letter S are?
PROFESSOR: Yes,
sorry about that.
R would be the odd
ratio-- so it's
the ratio of the
probability of generating
that sequence under
the foreground
model-- the plus
model, we're calling
it-- divided by the probability
under the background,
or minus, model.
And then, I think I
pointed out last time
that when you get
products of probabilities,
they tend to get very small.
This can cause
computational problems.
And so if you just take the
log, you convert it into a sum.
And so we'll often
use score, or S,
for the log of the odds ratio.
Sorry, should have
marked that more clearly.
So Markov models can
improve performance,
when there is dependence,
and when you have enough data
to estimate the increased
number of parameters.
And it doesn't just
have to be dependence
on the previous base--
you can have a model where
the probability of
the next base depends
on the two previous bases.
That would be called a
second-order Markov model,
or in general, a
K-order Markov model.
Sometimes, these dependencies
actually occur in practice.
With five-prime splice
sites, it's a nice example,
because there's probably
a couple thousand of them
in the human genome, and
we know them very well,
so you can make
quite complex models
and have enough
data to train them.
But in general,
if you're thinking
about modeling a transcription
factor binding site,
or something, often you might
have dozens or, at best,
hundreds of examples, typically.
And so you might not
have enough to train
some of the larger model.
So how many
parameters do you need
to fit a K-order Markov model?
So question first, yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
If you're comparing
the first-order Markov models
with W M M, what is W M M?
PROFESSOR: Weight matrix, or
position-specific probability
matrix.
Just a model of independence
between the two.
Coming back to this case.
So let's suppose
you are thinking
about making a
K-order Markov model,
because you do some
statistical tasks
and you find there's some
dependence between sets
of positions in your motif.
How many parameters
would there be?
So if you have an independence
model, or weight matrix
or position-specific
probability matrix,
there are four parameters
at each position,
the probabilities
of the four bases.
This will be only
three free parameters,
because the fourth one-- but
let's just think about it
as four, four parameters
times the width of the motif.
So if I now go to a
first-order Markov model,
now there's more
parameters, because I
have these conditional
probabilities at each position.
So how many
parameters are there?
For a first-order Markov?
How many do I need to estimate?
Yeah, Kevin?
AUDIENCE: I think it would
be 16 at each position.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, 16
at each position,
except the first
position, which has four.
OK, and what about a
second-order Markov model,
where you condition on the
two previous positions?
64, right?
Because you have two possible
bases you're conditioning on,
that's 16 possibilities times 4.
And so in general, the
formula is 4 to the k plus 1.
This is really the issue-- if
you have only 100 sequences,
and you need to estimate 64
parameters at each position,
you don't have enough
data to estimate those.
So you shouldn't use
such a high order model.
All right, so let's
think about this--
what could happen if you don't
have enough data to estimate
parameters, and how can
you get around that?
So let's just take a
very simple example.
So suppose you were setting
a new transcription factor.
You had done some sort of
pull-down assay, followed
by, say, conventional
sequencing,
and identified 10
sequences that bind
to that transcription factor.
And these are the 10
sequences, and you align them.
You see there is
sort of a pattern
there-- there's usually an
A at the first position,
and usually a C at the
second, and so forth.
And so you consider making
a weight matrix model.
Then you tally up-- there's
eight A's, one C, one G,
and no T's at the
first position.
So how confident can
you be that T is not
compatible with binding of
this transcription factor?
Who thinks you can
be very confident?
Most of you are
shaking your head.
So if you're not confident,
why are you not confident?
I think-- wait, were
you shaking your head?
What's the problem here?
It's just too small
a sample, right?
Maybe T occurs rarely.
So suppose that T occurs
at a frequency of 10%,
what's the probability of
that in natural sequences?
And we just have a
random sample of those.
What's the probability
we wouldn't
see any T's in a
sample of size 10?
Anyone have an idea?
Anyone have a ballpark
number on this?
Yeah, Simona?
AUDIENCE: 0.9 to the 10th.
PROFESSOR: 0.9 to the 10th, OK.
And what is that?
AUDIENCE: 0.9 is the probability
that you grab one, and don't
see a T, and then
you do that 10 times.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
In genera it's a binomial
thing, but it works out
to be 0.9 to the 10th.
And that's roughly--
this is like a Poisson.
There's a mean of 1, so it's
roughly E to the minus 1,
so about 35% chance that
you don't see any T's.
So we really shouldn't
be confident.
T probably doesn't have
a frequency of 0.5,
but it could easily have a
frequency of 10% or even 5%,
or even 15%.
And you might have
just not seen it.
So you don't want to assign
a probability 0 to T.
But what value should you assign
for something you haven't seen?
Sally?
So, it turns out there
is a principled way
to do this called pseudocounts.
So basically, if you use
maximum likelihood estimation,
you get-- maximum
likelihood, it turns out,
is equal to the
observed frequency.
But if you assume that the
true frequency is unknown,
but was sampled from
all possible, reasonable
frequencies-- so that's a
Dirichlet distribution-- then
you can calculate what the
posterior distribution is
in a Bayesian framework, given
that you observed, for example,
zero T's, what's
the distribution
of that parameter,
frequency of T?
And it turns out, it's
equivalent to adding
a single count to
each of your bins.
I'm not going to go
through the derivation,
because it takes
time, but it is well
described in the appendix
of a book called,
Biological Sequence
Analysis, published about 10,
15 years ago by a number of
leaders in the field-- Durbin,
Eddy, Krogh, and Mitchison.
And there's also a derivation
of this in the probability
and statistics primer.
So basically you just do
this poster calculation,
and it turns out to be
equivalent to adding 1 count.
So when you add 1 count--
and then, of course,
you re-normalize,
and then you get
a frequency-- what
effectively it does
is it will reduce the
frequency of things
that you observe most commonly,
and boost up the things
that you don't see, so
that you actually end up
assigning a probability
of 0.07 to T.
Now, if you had a
larger sample-- so
let's imagine instead of 8
1 1 0, it was 80 10 10 0,
you still at a single count.
So you can see in
that case, you're
only going to be adding a very
small, close to 1%, for T.
So as you get more
data, it converges
to the maximum
likelihood estimate.
But it does something more
reasonable, more open-minded,
in a case where you're really
limited in terms of data.
So the limitation--
you always want
to be aware when
you're considering
going to a more complex model to
get better predictability-- you
want to be aware of
how much data you have,
and whether you have enough to
accurately estimate parameters.
And if you don't, you
either simplify the model,
or if you can't
simplify it anymore,
consider using pseudocounts.
Sometimes you'll see
smaller pseudocounts added--
like instead of 1
1 1 1, you might
see a quarter, one pseudocount
distributed across the four
bins.
There's arguments pro and
con, which I won't go into.
So for the remainder
of today, I want
to introduce hidden
Markov models.
We'll talk about
some the terminology,
some applications, and the
Viterbi algorithm-- which
is a core algorithm when
using HMMs to predict things--
and then we'll give
a couple examples.
So we'll talk about
the CpG Island
HMM, which is about the
simplest HMM I could think of,
which is good for illustrating
the mechanics of HMM.
And then a couple
later, probably
coming into the next
lecture, some examples
of real-world
HMMs, like one that
predicts transmembrane helices.
So some background reading
for today's lecture
that's posted on
the course website,
there's a nature
biotechnology primer on HMMs,
there's a little
bit in the textbook.
But really, if you want to
understand the guts of HMMs,
you should read the
Rabiner tutorial,
which is really
pretty well done.
For Thursday's lecture, I will
post another of these nature
biotechnology primers
on RNA folding.
This one is actually has
a little bit more content,
takes a little bit
longer to absorb probably
than some of the
others, but still
a good introduction
to the topic.
And then it turns out the
text has a pretty good section
on RNA folding, so take
a look at chapter 11.
So hidden Markov
models can be thought
of as a general approach
for modeling sequence
labeling problems--
you have sequences,
they might be genomic
sequences, protein sequences,
RNA sequences.
And these sequences have
features-- promoters,
they may have domains,
et cetera, linear motifs.
And you want to
label those features
in an unknown sequence.
So a classical example
would be gene finding.
You have a genomic sequence,
some parts are, say, exon,
some are introns.
You want to be able to
label them, it's not known.
But you might have a training
set of known exons and introns,
and you might learn what the
sequence composition of each
of those labels
looks like, and then
make a model that
builds things together.
And what they allow you
to do, though, with HMMs
is to have transition
probabilities
between the different states.
You could model
states, you can model
the length of different types
of states to some extent--
as we'll see-- and
you can model which
states need to
follow other states.
They're relatively
easy to design,
you can just simply
draw a graph.
It can even have cycles
in it, that's OK.
And they've been
described as the LEGOs
of computational
sequence analysis.
They were developed originally
in electrical engineering
four or five decades
ago for applications
in voice recognition,
and they're still
used in voice recognition.
So when you are calling up some
large corporation, and instead
of a person answering
the phone, some computer
answering the phone
and attempting
to recognize your
voice, it could well
be an HMM on the other end,
which is either correctly
recognizing what
you're saying, or not.
So you can thank them or
blame them, as you wish.
All right, so Markov Model
example-- we did this before,
imagine the genotype
at a particular locus,
and successive generations is
thought of as a Markov chain.
Bart's genotype depends on
Homer's, but is conditionally
independent of Grandpa
Simpson's, given Homer's.
So now what's a
hidden Markov model?
So imagine that our
DNA sequencer is not
working that week,
we can't actually
go in and measure the genotype.
But instead, we're going to
observe some phenotype that's
dependent on genotype.
But it's not dependent
in a deterministic way,
it's dependent in a more
complex way, because there's
an impact of environment,
as well, let's say.
So we're imagining that your
genotype at the apolipoprotein
locus is correlated
with cholesterol,
but doesn't
completely predict it.
So you're homozygous, you tend
to have higher LDL cholesterol
than you are heterozygous.
But there's a
distribution depending
on how many doughnuts you
eat, or something like that.
Imagine that we
observe that grandpa
had low cholesterol, 150,
Homer had high cholesterol,
and Bart's cholesterol
is intermediate.
Now if we had just observed
Bart's cholesterol,
we would say, well, it
could go either way.
It could be homozygous
or heterozygous.
You would just look at
the population frequency
of those two, and would
use that to guess.
But remember, we know his
father's cholesterol, which
was 250, makes it
much more likely
that his father was homozygous,
and then that, in turn, biases
the distribution
[? of it. ?] So that'll
make it a little bit more
likely that Bart, himself, is
homozygous, if you didn't know.
So this is the basic idea-- you
have some observable phenotype,
if you will, that depends,
in a probabilistic way,
on something hidden.
And that hidden thing has some
dependent structure to it.
And you want to, then,
predict those hidden states
from the observable data.
So we'll give some more
examples coming up.
And the way to think about these
models, or at least a handy way
to think about them, is
as generative models.
And so this is from
the Rabiner tutorial--
you imagine an HMM used
in order to generate
observable sequences.
So there's these hidden
states-- think of them
as genotypes--
observable-- think
of them as the
cholesterol levels.
So the way that it works is
you choose an initial state
from one of your
possible hidden states,
according to some
initial distribution,
you set the time
variable equal to 1.
In this case, it's T,
which will, in our case,
often be the position
in the sequence.
And then you choose
an observed value,
according to some
probability distribution,
but it depends on what
that hidden state was.
And then you transition
to a new state,
and then you emit another one.
So we'll do an example.
Let's say bacterial gene
finding is our application,
and we're going to model
a bacterial gene-- these
are protein coding genes,
only it's got to have a start
coat on, it's got to have
an open reading frame,
and then it's got to
have a stop code on it.
So how many different states
do we need in our HMM?
What should our states be?
Anyone?
Do you want to make that-- Tim?
AUDIENCE: Maybe you
need four states,
because the start state, the
orf state, the stop state,
and the non-genic state.
PROFESSOR: OK, start, orf,
stop and then intergenic,
or non-genic.
OK now, remember these
are the hidden states,
so what are they going to emit?
They emit observable
data, what's
that observable
data going to be?
Sequence, OK.
And how many bases of sequence
should each of them emit?
AUDIENCE: Well I
guess we don't know.
PROFESSOR: You have a choice.
You're the model builder,
you can do anything you want.
1, 5, 10-- any number
of bases you want.
And they can emit different
things, if you want.
This is generative,
you can do anything
you want-- there will
be consequences later,
but for now-- I'm going
to call this-- go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You could start with
the start and the stop states
maybe being three.
PROFESSOR: Three, OK.
So this is going to
emit three nucleotides.
How about this state?
What should this emit?
AUDIENCE: Any number.
PROFESSOR: Any number?
Yeah, OK, Sally?
AUDIENCE: If you let
it emit one number,
and then add a self-cycle,
then that would work.
PROFESSOR: So Sally wants
to have this state emit one
nucleotide, but she
wants it to have
a chance of returning to itself.
So that then we can have strings
of N's to represent intergenic.
Does that make sense?
And these, I agree.
Three is a good choice, here.
If you had this one emit
three, as well, then
your genes would have to
be a multiple of three
apart from each other,
which isn't realistic.
You would miss out on
some genes for that.
So this has to be able to
emit arbitrary numbers.
So you could either have it
emit an arbitrary number,
but it's going to turn
out to make the Viterbi
algorithm easier if it
just emits one and recurs,
as Sally suggested.
And then we have our orf state.
So how about here?
What should we do here?
AUDIENCE: It can be
three, and then you
put the circle [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So I'm going to
change the name to Codon,
because it's going to emit
one codon-- three nucleotides.
And then recur to itself.
And now what transitions
should we allow between states?
AUDIENCE: So start to four,
orf to stop, then stop to N,
and then to start.
PROFESSOR: Any others?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: N could
go to stop, as well.
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry,
N could go to stop?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so that
the gene [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so
that's a question.
We're thinking of a
gene on the plus strand,
a gene could well be
on the opposite strand.
And so we should
probably make a model
of where you would hit stop
on the other strand, which
would emit a triplet of the
inverse complement of the stop
code, [INAUDIBLE] et cetera.
That's true, excellent point.
And then you would
traverse this whole circle
in the opposite direction.
But it wouldn't
be the same state.
It would be stop-- because it
would emit different things.
So you'd have minus
stop, stop minus strand.
And then you'd have
some other states there.
And I'm not going to draw
those, but that's a point.
And you could have a
teeny one-codon gene
if you want, but
probably not worth it.
All right, everyone have
an idea about this HMM?
So this is a model you have
to specify in order for this
to actually generate sequence.
This model will
actually generate
annotations and sequence.
You have to specify
where to start,
so you have to have some
probability of starting,
but the first base that
you're going to generate
is going to begin intergenic,
or start, or codon, et cetera.
And you might give it a
high probability of this,
and then it'll generate a label.
So for example, let's say N.
And then it'll generate a base,
let's say G.
And then you look at
these probabilities,
so the transition probability
here, versus this-- you either
generate another N, or
you generate a start.
And let's say you go
to start, and then
you'll generate three
bases, so A T G.
And then you would go
to the codon state,
you would emit some other
triplet, and so forth.
So this is a model that will
generate strings of annotations
with associated bases.
Still doesn't predict
gene structure yet,
but at least it generates
gene structures.
All right, so we are going to,
for the sake of illustrating
the Viterbi
algorithm, we're going
to use a simpler HMM in that.
So this one only has two
states, and its purpose
is to predict CPG islands
in a vertebrate genome.
So what are CPG islands?
Anyone remember?
What is a CPG island?
Anyone heard of this?
I'm sure some of you.
Well, the definition
here is going
to be regions of high CNG
content, and relatively high
abundance of CPG dinucleotides,
which are unmethylated.
So what is the P here?
The p means that the
CG we're talking about
is C followed by G along
the particular DNA strand,
just to distinguish it
from C base paired with G.
We're not talking
about a base pair here,
we're talking about
C and G following
each other along the strand.
So this dinucleotide is
rare in vertebrate genomes,
because CPG is the
site of a methylase,
and methylation of the C
is mutogenic-- it lends
to a much higher
rate of mutations.
so CPGs often mutate
away, except for the ones
that are necessary.
But there are certain
regions, often near promoters,
that are unmethylated,
and therefore, CPGs
can accumulate to
higher frequencies.
And so you can actually
look for these regions
and use them to predict
where promoters are.
That's one application.
So they have higher CPG
dinucleotide content, and also
higher C and G content.
The background of the human
genome is about 40% C G only,
so it's a bit AT rich, and so
you see these patches of, say,
50% to 60% C G that are often
associated with promoters,
with promoters of roughly
half of human genes.
So we're going to-- I always
drop that little clicker thing.
Here it is.
We're going to make
a model of these,
and then run it to predict
promoters in the gene.
So here's our model.
We have two states, we
have a genome state--
this sort of generic
position in the genome--
and then we have
an island state.
We have the simplest
possible transitions,
you can go genome to
genome, genome to island,
island to genome,
or island to island.
So now you can generate islands
of arbitrary size, interspersed
with genomic regions
of arbitrary size.
And then each of
those hidden states
is going to emit a single base.
So a CPG island in
this model is a stretch
of I states in a row flanked
by G states, if you will.
Everyone clear on this set up?
Good.
So here, in order to
fully specify the model,
you need to say what
all the parameters are.
And there are really
three class of parameters.
There are initiation
probabilities--
so the green here is the
notation used in the Rabiner
tutorial, except they call them
[? pi ?] [? j's. ?] So here,
I'm going to say it's a 99%
chance you start in the generic
genome state, and a 1% chance
you start in an island state,
because islands are
not that common.
And then you need to specify
transition probabilities.
So there's four possible
transitions you could make,
and you need to assign
probabilities to them.
So if the average length of
an island were 1,000 bases,
then a reasonable value
for the I to I transition
would be 0.999.
You have 99.9% chance of
making another island,
and 0.1% chance of
leaving that island state.
If you just run that in
this generative mode,
it would generate a variety
of lengths of islands,
but on average, they'd
be about one kb long,
because the probability of
terminating is one in 1,000.
And then if we imagine that
those one kb islands are
interspersed with genomic
regions that are about, say,
100 kilo bases long on average,
then you would get this
[? five ?] [? nines ?]
probability for P G G,
and 10 to the minus fifth as
a probability of going from
genome to islands.
That would generate
widely spaced islands,
that are on average
100 kb apart,
that are about one kb in length.
Is that making sense?
And now the third type of
probability we need to specify
are called emission
probabilities,
which are the B J K
in Rabiner notation.
And this is where the predictive
power is going to come in.
There has to be a
difference in the emissions
if you're going to
have any ability
to predict these
features, and so we're
going to imagine that
the genome is 40% C G,
and islands are 60% C G.
So it's a base composition
that we're modeling.
We're not doing the
dinucleotides here,
that would make it
more complicated.
We're just looking for
patches of high G C content.
So now we've fully
specified our model.
The problem here
is that the model
is written from the
hidden generating
the observable, and the problem
we're faced with, in practice,
is that we have the
observable sequence,
and we want to go
back to the hidden.
So we need to reverse
the conditioning that's
in the model.
So when you see this
type of problem,
how do you reverse conditioning?
In general, what's
a good way to do it?
You see P A, given
B, but the model
you have is written in P
B, given A. What do you do?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Bayes theorem.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, Bayes theorem.
Right, let's do
base theorem here.
Remember, definition of
conditional probability,
if we have P A given B--
so this might be the hidden
states, given the observables--
we want to write that in terms
of P B given A. So
what we do first?
How do we derive Bayes rule?
You first write the definition
of conditional probability--
right, that's just
the definition.
And now what do I do?
Split the top part into what?
AUDIENCE: A times P of
B given [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: P B
given A. That's just
another way of writing
joint probability of P A B,
using the definition of
conditional probability again.
So now it's written
the other way.
That's basically the idea.
So this is the simple form.
And like I said, I
don't usually call it
a theorem, because
it's so simple-- it's
something you can
derive in 30 seconds.
It should be called maybe
a rule, or something.
There is a more general form.
This is where you have
two states, basically B
or not B that
you're dealing with.
And there's this
more general form
that's shown on the slide, which
is when you have many states.
And it basically
is the same idea,
it's just that we've
rewritten this term, this P B,
and we split it up into
all the possible states.
The slide starts from PB given
A and goes the other-- anyway,
so you rewrite the
bottom term as a sum
of all the possible cases.
All right, so how does
that apply to HMMs?
So with HMMs, we're interested
in the joint probability
of a set of hidden states, and
a set of observable states.
So H, capital H, is
going to be a vector that
specifies the particular hidden
state-- for instance, island
or genome-- at position 1,
that's H1 all the way to H N.
So little h's are specific
values for those hidden state.
And then, big O is a
vector that describes
the different bases
in the genome.
So O1 is the first
base in the genome,
up to O N. One can imagine
comparing two H vectors,
one of which, H versus the
H primes, what's the what's
the probability of this
hidden state versus that?
You could compare them in terms
of their joint probabilities
with this model,
and perhaps favor
those that have
higher probabilities.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
of the two capital
H's have any different notation?
Like the second one being H
prime, or something like that?
Or are they supposed to be--
PROFESSOR: With the
H, in this case,
these are probability statements
about random variables.
So H is a random
variable, which could
assume any possible
sequence of hidden states.
The little h's are
specific values.
So for instance,
imagine comparing
what's the probability of
H equals genome, genome,
genome, versus the
probability that H
equals genome, genome, island.
So the little h's, or
the little h primes,
are specific instances.
The H's is a random
variable, unknown.
Does that help?
OK, so how do we
apply Bayes' rule?
So what we're interested
in here is the probability
that H, this unknown variable
that represents hidden states,
that it equals a particular
set of hidden states,
little h1 to h N, given
the observables, little
o1 to little oN, which is the
actual sequence that we see.
And we can write
that using definition
of conditional probability
as the joint probability
patient of H and O, over
the probability of O.
And then Bayes' rule, we just
apply conditional probability
again.
It's P H times P O,
given H, over P O.
So it turns out that
this P O-- so what is P O
equals O1 to O N in this model?
Well, the model specifies how
to generate the hidden states,
and how the observables are
generated from those hidden
states.
So P O is actually defined
as the sum of P O comma H
equals the first possible
hidden state, plus the same term
for the second.
You have to sum over all
the possible outcomes
of the hidden states,
every possible thing.
So if we have a sequence
of length three,
you have to sum
over the possibility
that H might be G G G or
G G I, or G I G, or G I I,
or I G G, et cetera.
You have to sum over
eight possibilities here.
And if the sequence
is a million long,
you have to sum over 2 to the
one millionth possibilities.
That sounds complicated
to calculate.
So it turns out that
there's actually a trick,
and you can calculate it.
But you don't have to.
That's one of the
good things, is
that we can just treat
it as a constant.
So notice that the denominator
here is independent of the H's.
So we'll just treat that as a
constant, an unknown constant.
And what we're interested
in, which possible value of H
has a higher probability?
So we're just going to try to
maximize P H equals H1 to H N--
find the optimal
sequence of hidden states
that optimizes that
joint probability,
the joint probability with
the observable values,
O1 to O N. Is that making sense?
Basically, we want to find
the sequence of hidden states,
we'll call it H opt.
So now H opt here is
a particular vector.
Capital H, by itself,
is a random vector.
This is now a particular
vector of hidden states,
H1 opt through H N opt.
And it's defined as the
vector of hidden states
that maximizes the joint
probability with O equals
O1 to O N, where that's the
observed sequence that we're
dealing with.
So now what I'm
telling you is if we
can find the vector
of hidden states
that maximizes the
joint probability,
then that will also maximize
the conditional probability of H
given O. And that's often
the language of linguistics
is used, and it's called the
optimal parse of the sequence.
You'll see that sometimes,
I might say that.
So the solution is to
define these variables,
R I of H, which are
defined as the probability
of the optimal parse of
the subsequence from one
to I-- not the
whole long sequence,
but a little piece of
it from the beginning
to a particular place in the
middle, that ends in state, H.
And so first.
We calculate R, R 1
1, the probability
of generating the
first base, given
that it ended in hidden state 1.
And then we would do
the hidden state 2,
and then we basically have to
figure out a way, a recursion,
for getting the probabilities
of the optimal parses ending
at each of the
states at position 2,
given the values at position 1.
And then we go, work
our way all the way
down to the end of the sequence.
And then we'll figure
out which is better,
and then we'll
backtrack to figure out
what that optimal parse was.
We'll do an example
on the board,
this is unlikely to be
completely clear at this point.
But don't worry.
So why is this called
the Viterbi algorithm?
Well, this is the guy
who figured it out.
He was actually an MIT alum.
He did his bachelor's
and master's in double E,
I don't know, quite
awhile ago, '50s or '60s.
And later went on
to found Qualcomm,
and is now big philanthropist,
who apparently supports USC.
I don't know why he
lost his loyalty to MIT,
but maybe he'll come back
and give us a seminar.
I actually met him once.
Let's talk about his
algorithm a little more.
So what I want to do is I
want to take a particular HMM,
so we'll take our
CPG island HMM,
and then we'll go through
the actual Viterbi
algorithm on the board
for a particular sequence.
And you'll see that it's
actually pretty simple.
But then you'll
also see that it's
not totally obvious
why it works.
The mechanics of it
are not that bad,
but the understanding
really how it
is able to come up with
the optimal parses, that's
the more subtle part.
So let's suppose
we have a sequence,
A C G. Can anyone tell
me what the optimal parse
of this sequence is,
without doing Viterbi?
With this particular
model, these initiation
probabilities transitions
and emissions?
Do you know what it's
going to be in advance?
Any guesses?
AUDIENCE: How about
genome, island, island.
PROFESSOR: Genome,
island, island.
Because, you're saying,
that way the emissions
will be optimized, right?
Because you'll omit
the C's and G's.
OK, that's a reasonable guess.
Sally's shaking
her head, though.
AUDIENCE: The
transitional probability
from being in the genome
is very, very small,
and so it's more likely
that it'll either only
be in the genome or
only be in the island.
PROFESSOR: So the
transition from going
from a genome to island or
island to genome is very small,
and so she's saying you're
going to pay a bigger
penalty for making that
transition in there, that
may not be offset
by the emissions.
Right, is that your point?
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Check here-- when
we're talking about the optimal
parse, we're saying let's
maximize the probability
of that letter--
PROFESSOR: The
joint probability.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, the joint
probability of that letter--
PROFESSOR: Of that [INAUDIBLE]
state and that letter.
AUDIENCE: OK, so that means--
PROFESSOR: Or that set
of [INAUDIBLE] states
and that set of bases.
AUDIENCE: So when
we're computing
across this
three-letter thing, we
have to say the probability
of the letter, then let's
multiply if by the
probability of the transition
to the next letter, and
then multiply it again
[INAUDIBLE] and that letter.
PROFESSOR: So let's do this.
If A C G is our
sequence-- I'm just
going to space it
out a little bit.
Here's our A at position one,
here's our C at position two,
and our G at position three.
And then we have
our hidden states.
And so we'll write genome first,
and then we have island here.
And so what is the optimal
parse of the sequence from base
one to base one,
that ends in genome?
It's just the one
that starts in genome,
because it doesn't go--
right, so it's just genome.
And what is its probability?
That's how this thing
is defined here.
This is this R I H thing
I was talking about.
This is H, and this is I here.
So the probability
of the optimal parse
of the sequence, up to position
one, that ends in genome,
is just the one that
starts in genome,
and then emits that base.
So what's the probability
of starting in genome?
It's five nines, right?
So that's the initial
probability-- 9 9 9 9 9.
And then what's the probability
of emitting an A, given
that we're in the genome state?
0.3.
So I claim that
this is the value
of R1 of genome, of
the genome state.
OK, that's the optimal parse.
There's only one
parse, so there's
nothing-- it is what it is.
You start here, there's no
transitions-- we started here--
and then you emit an A.
What's the probability
of the optimal parse
ending an island at position
one of the sequence?
Someone else?
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Why are we using
the transition probability?
PROFESSOR: This is the
initial-- Oh, I'm sorry.
Correct.
Thank you, thank you--
what was your name?
AUDIENCE: Deborah.
PROFESSOR: Deborah,
OK, thanks Deborah.
It should be the
initial probability,
which is 0.99, good.
Initial probability.
What about island?
Deborah, you want
to take this one?
AUDIENCE: 0.01.
PROFESSOR: 0.01 to be an island.
And what about the
emission probability?
We have to start
an island, and then
emit an A, which
is probably what?
AUDIENCE: 0.2.
PROFESSOR: 0.2, yeah,
it's up on the screen.
Should be, hopefully.
Yeah, 0.02.
So who's winning so far?
If the sequences
ended at position one?
Genome, genome's winning.
This is a lot bigger
than that, it's
about 150 times bigger, right?
Now what do when we go-- we said
we have to do recursion, right?
We have to figure
out the probability
of the optimal parse ending
at position two in each
of these states, given
the optimal parse ending
at position one.
How do we figure that out?
What are we going to
write here, or what
do we have to compare to
figure out what to put here?
There's two possible
parses ending in genome
at position two--
there's the one that
started in genome
at position one,
and there's the one
that started at island.
So you have to
compare this to this.
So you compare what the
probability of this parse
was times the
transition probability,
and then the emission
in that state.
So what would that be?
What would this be,
if we stay in genome?
What's the transition?
Now we've got our five
nines, yeah, good.
So five nines.
And the emission is what?
AUDIENCE: Genome at 0.2.
PROFESSOR: 0.2, right.
And times this.
And what about this one?
What are we going
to multiply when
we consider this island
to genome transition?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] 0.01?
Because the genome is still 0.2.
PROFESSOR: It's still 0.2.
So we take the maximum
of these, right?
We're doing optimal parse,
highest probability.
So which one of these
two turns this bigger?
Clearly, the top one is bigger.
This one is already
bigger than this,
and we're multiplying
by the same data,
so clearly the answer
here is 0.99 times
0.3 times-- my nines
are going to have
to get really skinny
here-- 0.99999 and 0.2.
That's the winner.
And the other thing we do,
besides recording this number,
is we circle this arrow.
Does this ring a bell?
This is sort of
like Needleman-Wench
or Smith-Waterman,
where you don't just
record what's the
best score, but you
remember how you got there.
We're going to need that later.
And what about here?
What's the optimal
parse-- what's
the probability of the
optimal parse ending
in island at position two?
Or what do I have to
do to calculate it?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: You have to
calculate the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, you consider
going genome to island here,
and island to island.
And who's going
to win that race?
Do you have an idea?
Genome to island
had a head start,
but it pays a penalty
for the transition.
The transition is pretty small,
that's 10 to the minus fifth.
And what about this one?
This has a much higher
transition probability
of 0.999.
And so even though you were
starting from something,
this is about 150 times
smaller than this.
But this is being multiplied
by 10 to the minus fifth,
and this is being multiplied
by something that's around 1.
So this one will win,
island to island will win.
Everyone agree on that?
And what will that value be?
So it's whatever
it was before times
the transition, which is what?
From island to island?
999.
Times the emission which is?
0.3.
Island is more
likely [? to omit ?]
a C. Everyone clear on that?
And then, we're not that until
we circle this arrow here.
That was the winner, the
winner was coming from island,
remaining on island.
And then we keep
going like this.
Do you want me to
do one more base?
How many people want
me to do one more base,
and how many people
want me to stop this?
I'll do one more
base, but you guys
will have to help
me a little bit.
Who is going to
win-- now we want
the probability of the
optimal parse ending in G,
ending at position three, which
is a G, and ending in genome,
or ending in island.
So for ending in genome, where
is that one going to come from?
Which is going to win?
This one, or this one?
AUDIENCE: Stay in genome.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, stay in
genome is going to win.
This one is already
bigger than this,
and the transition
probability here-- this
is a 10 to minus 3
transition probability.
And this is a probability
that's near one,
so the transitions are
going to dominate here.
And so you're going to
have this term-- I'm
going to call that R 2 of G.
That's this notation here.
And times the
transition probability,
genome to genome, which
is all these nines here.
And then the
emission probability
of a G in the
genome state is 0.2.
And who's going to win here
for the optimal parse, ending
at position three,
in the island state?
Is it going to be this guy,
to island, or this one,
changing from genome to island?
Island to island, because,
again, the transmission
probability is
prohibitive-- that's a 10
to the minus fifth
penalty there.
So you're going
to stay in island.
So this one won here,
and this one won here.
And so this term
here is R 2 of island
times the transition
probability, island to island,
which is 0.999 times the
emission probability, which
is 0.3 of a G in
the island state.
Everyone clear on that?
Now, if we went out another 20
bases, what's going to happen?
Probably not a lot.
Probably the same kind of
stuff that's happening.
That seems kind of
boring, but when would
we actually get a cross?
What would it take?
To push you over and cause
you to transition from one
to the other?
AUDIENCE: Slowly stacked
against you or long enough?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
a good way to put it.
So let me give you an example.
This is the Viterbi algorithm,
written out mathematically.
We can go over this in
a moment, but I just
want to try to stay
with the intuition here.
We did that, now
I want to do this.
Suppose your sequence is A C
G T, repeating 10,000 times.
Can anyone figure out what the
optimal parse of that sequence
would be, without doing
Viterbi in their head?
Start and stay in genome.
Can you explain why?
AUDIENCE: Because
it's equal to the--
what are the
[? widths? ?] Because it's
homogeneous to the
distributor, as opposed
to enriched for C N G, and it
just repeats without pattern.
Or it repeats throughout without
[? concentrating the C N Gs ?]
anywhere.
PROFESSOR: Right, so the unit of
the repeat, this A C G T unit,
is not biased for either one.
So there will be 2.3
emissions, and 2.2 emissions,
whether you go through
those in G G G G
or in I I I I. Does
that make sense?
So the emissions will be the
same, if you're all in genome,
or if you're all in island.
And the initial
probabilities favor genome,
and the transitions also
favor staying in genome.
Right, so all genome.
Can everyone see that?
So do you want to take
a stab at this next one?
This one's harder.
Let me ask you, in
the optimal parse,
what state is it
going to end in?
AUDIENCE: Genome.
PROFESSOR: Genome, you've got
to run [? with a 1,000 ?] T's.
And genome, the emissions
favor emitting T's.
So clearly, it's going
to end in genome.
And then, what about those runs
of C's and G's in the middle
there?
Are any of those long enough to
trigger a transition to island?
What was your name again?
AUDIENCE: Daniel.
PROFESSOR: Daniel, so
you're shaking your head.
You think they're
not long enough.
So you think the winner's
going to be genome all the way?
Who thinks they're long enough?
Or maybe some of them are?
Go ahead, what was your name?
AUDIENCE: Michael.
PROFESSOR: Michael, yeah.
AUDIENCE: The ones at length
80 and 60 are long enough,
but the one at length 20 is not.
PROFESSOR: OK, and
why do you say that?
AUDIENCE: Just looking
at power of 3 over 2,
3 times 10 to the 3 isn't enough
to overcome the difference
in transition probabilities
between the island and genome.
But 3 times 10 to the 10
and 1 times 10 to the 14
is, over the length
of those sequences.
The difference in
probability of making that
switch once at the
beginning [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, did everyone
get what Michael was saying?
So, Michael, can you
explain why powers of 1.5
are relevant here?
AUDIENCE: Oh, that's the
ratio of emission probability
between the C states
and the G states,
between island and genome.
So in island it's 0.3,
and in genome it's
0.2 over [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, so when you're
going through a run of C's,
if you're in the island
state, you get a power of 1.5,
in terms of emissions
at each position.
What about the transitions?
You're sort of
glossing over those.
Why is that?
AUDIENCE: Because that
only has to happen once
at the beginning.
So the ratio between the
transition probabilities
is really high, but as
long as the compounded
ratio of the
emission probability
is high enough
over a [INAUDIBLE]
of sequences, that as long
as that compound emission
is greater than that one-off
ratio at the beginning,
then the island is
more [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so if you think
about the transitions, I to I,
or G to G, as being close to 1--
so if you think of them as 1,
then you can ignore them,
and only focus on the cases
where it transitions
from G to I, and I to G.
So you say that 60 and
80 are long enough.
So your prediction is
at the optimal parse
is G 1,000 I 80
G another 2,020--
you said that one wasn't going
to-- and then I 60 G 1,000.
Michael, is that
what you're saying?
Can you read this?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK, so why do
you say that 10 to the 10th
is enough to flip the switch,
and 10 to the 3rd is not?
AUDIENCE: If I remember the
numbers from the previous slide
correctly--
PROFESSOR: A couple
of slides back?
AUDIENCE: So if you look at
the ratio of the probability
of staying in the genome, and
the probability of going from
the genome to the island, it's--
PROFESSOR: 10 to the 5th.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, 10 to the 5th.
So whatever happens going over
the next [? run ?] of sequences
has to overcome the difference
in ratio for the switch
to become more likely.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So if everyone agrees that
we're going to start in genome,
we've got a run of 1,000 A's,
and genome is favored anyway--
so that's clear, we're going to
be in genome at the beginning
for the first 1,000, and
be in genome at the end,
then if you're going
to go to island,
you have to pay two
penalties, basically.
You pay the penalty of
starting an island, which
is 10 to the minus 5th-- this is
maybe a slightly different way
than you were thinking
about it, but I
think it's equivalent-- 10 the
minus 5th to switch island,
and then you pay a penalty
coming back, 10 to the minus 3.
And all the other
transitions are near 1.
So it's like a 10 to
the minus 8 penalty
for going from genome
to island and back.
And so if the emissions
are greater than 10
to the 8th, favor island by
a gradient of 10 to the 8th,
it'll be worth doing that.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: I forgot about
the penalty of [INAUDIBLE],
but it's still the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
it's still true.
Everyone see that?
You have to pay a
penalty of 10 to the 8gh
to go from genome
to island and back.
But the emissions
can make up for that.
Even though it seems small,
it seems like 60 bases is not
enough-- it's multiplicative,
and it adds up.
Sally?
AUDIENCE: So it seems
like the [INAUDIBLE]
to me is going to
return a lagging answer,
because we're not going
to actually switch
to genome in our HMM until we
hit the point where we should
[? tip, ?] which would be about
60 G's into the run of 80.
PROFESSOR: So you're
saying it's not actually
going to predict
the right thing?
AUDIENCE: Do you have to rerun
the [INAUDIBLE] processing
to get it actually in
line to the correct thing?
PROFESSOR: What do
people think about this?
Yeah, comment?
AUDIENCE: That's
not quite the case,
because you [? pack it ?]
or you [? stack it ?] both
in the genome and
island possibilities,
and your transition
is the penalty.
So it's the highest
impact penalty.
So when you island to island
to island in that string of 80,
the transition
will only be valid
starting at the first one.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, we're
at position 1,000.
I think you're on
the right track here.
So I'm going to claim that
the Viterbi will transition
at the right place,
because it's actually
proven to generate
the optimal parse.
So I'm right, but I
totally get your intuition.
This is the key thing--
most people's intuition,
my intuition, everyone's
intuition when they first
hear about this is that it
seems like you don't transition
soon enough.
It seems like you have
to look into the future
to know to transition
at that place, right?
And obviously you can't
look into the future,
it's a recursion.
How does it work?
Clearly, this is going
to be the winner.
So let's go to position
1,001, that's the first C.
And this guy is going
to come from here,
this guy is the winner overall--
G 1,000 is clearly the winner.
But what about this guy?
Where's it coming from?
G 1,000, it's coming from there.
And in fact, the previous
guy came from G 1,000.
I 1,000 came from G
999, and so forth.
Now, here's the
interesting question.
What happens at 1,002?
Sally, I want you to tell
me what happens at 1,002.
Who wins here?
AUDIENCE: Genome.
PROFESSOR: Genome.
Who wins here?
AUDIENCE: Island.
PROFESSOR: Island.
It had been transitioning,
genome has got a head start,
so the best way
to beat an island
is to have been genome
as long as possible,
up until position 1,000.
And that was still
true at 1,001.
It's no longer true after that.
It was actually better to
have transitioned back here
to get that one extra
emission, that one power of 1.5
from emitting that C
in the island state.
If you're going to
be in island anyway--
this is much lower than
this, at this point.
It's about 10 to the 5th lower.
But that's OK, we still keep it.
It's the best that
ends in island.
Do you see what I'm saying?
OK, there were all
these-- island always
had to come from genome at
the latest possible time, up
until this point, and
now it's actually better
to have made that transition
there, and then stay in island.
So you can see island is
going to win for awhile,
and then it'll flip back.
And the question is going
to be down here at 1,060,
going to 1,061.
Who's bigger here?
This guy was perhaps--
well, we don't even
know exactly how we got here.
But you can see that this
parse here that stays in island
is going to be optimal.
And the question is, would
it be just staying in genome?
And the answer is yes, because
it gained 10 to the 10th
in emissions, overcomes
the 10 to the 8th penalty
that it paid.
Now what do you do at the end?
How do you actually find
the optimal parse overall?
I go out to position
whatever it is, 4,160.
I've got a probability
here, probability here,
what do I do with those?
Right, but what do I do first?
You pick the bigger one,
whichever one's bigger.
We decided that this one is
going to be bigger, right?
And then remember all the
arrows that I circled?
You just backtrack through
and figure out what it was.
Does that make sense?
That's the Viterbi algorithm.
We'll do it a little bit
more on this next time,
or definitely field questions.
It's a little bit tricky
to get your head around.
It's a dynamic programming
algorithm, like Needleman-Wench
or Smith-Waterman, but
a little bit different.
The runtime-- what
is the runtime,
for those who were
sleeping and didn't notice
that little thing
I flashed up there?
Or, if you read it, can you
explain where it comes from?
How does the runtime depend
on the number of hidden states
and the length of the sequence?
I've got K states, sequence of
length L, what is the runtime?
So I'm going to
put this up here.
This might help.
So when you look at the
recursion like this,
when you want to think
about the runtime--
forget about initialization
and termination, that's not
[INAUDIBLE].
It's what you do on the
typical intermediate state that
determines the runtime.
That's what grows
with sequence length.
So what do you have
to do at each--
to go from position I
to position I plus 1?
How many calculations?
AUDIENCE: You have to do
N calculations for 33.
Is that right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so 33.
Yeah, the notation
is a little bit
different, but how many--
let me ask you this,
how many transitions do
you have to consider?
If I have an HMM
with K hidden states?
AUDIENCE: K squared.
PROFESSOR: K squared, right?
So you're going to have to
do K squared calculations,
basically, to go from
position I to I plus 1.
So what is the
overall dependence
on K and L, the length
of the sequence?
OK, it's K squared L. It's
linear in the sequence.
So is this good or bad?
Yes, Sally?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't this assume
that the graph is complete?
And if you don't
actually have [INAUDIBLE]
you can get a little faster?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
it's a good point.
So this is the
worst case, or this
is in the case where you can
transition from any state
to any other state.
If you remember, the
gene finding HMM--
I might have erased it,
I think I erased it--
if you can see this subtle--
No, remember Tim designed
an HMM for gene-finding
here, which only had some
of the arrows were allowed.
So if that's true, if there's
a bunch of zero probabilities
for transitions, then
you can ignore those,
and it actually speeds it up.
That's true.
It's a good point.
Everyone got this?
So this the worst case.
K squared L-- is
this good or bad?
Fast or slow?
Slow?
I mean, it depends on the
structure of your HMM.
For a simple HMM, like
the CPG island HMM,
this is like blindingly fast.
K squared is 4, right?
So it takes the same
order of magnitude
as just reading the sequence.
So it'll be super, super fast.
If you make a really complicated
HMM, it can be slower.
But the point is that for
genomic sequence analysis,
L is big.
So as long as you keep
K small, it'll run fast.
It's much better than sequence
comparison, where you end up
with these L squared
types of things.
So it's faster than
sequence comparison.
So that's really
one of the reasons
why Viterbi is so popular,
is it's super fast.
So in the last couple
minutes, I just
want to say a few things
about the midterm.
You guys did remember
there is a mid-term, right?
So the midterm is a week from
today, Tuesday, March 18.
For everybody, it's
going to be here,
except for those
who are in 6874--
and those people
should go to 68 180.
And because they're going
to be given extra time,
you should go there early.
Go there at 12:40.
Everyone else,
who's not in 6784,
should come here to the
regular class by 1:00 PM,
just so you have a chance to
get set up and everything.
And then the exam will
start promptly at 1:05,
and will end at 2:25,
an hour and 20 minutes.
It is closed book, open notes.
So don't bring your textbook,
but you can bring up
to two pages-- they
can be double sided
if you want-- of notes.
So why do we do this?
Well, we think that the act
of going through the lectures
and textbook, or whatever
other notes you have,
and deciding what's most
important, maybe helpful.
And so this, hopefully, will be
a useful studying exercise, so
figure out what's most
important and write it down
on a piece of paper if you are
likely to forget it-- maybe
complicated
equations, things like
that, you might
want to write down.
No calculators or
other electronic aids.
But you won't need them.
If you get an answer that's
e squared over 17 factorial--
you're asked to convert
that into a decimal.
Just leave it like that.
So what should you study?
So you should study your lecture
notes, readings and tutorials,
and past exams.
Past exams have been posted
to the course website.
p-sets as well.
The midterm exams from
past years are posted.
And there's some variation
in topics from year to year,
so if you're reading through
a midterm from a past year,
and you run across an
unfamiliar phrase or concept,
you have to ask
yourself, was I just
dozing off when
that was discussed?
Or was that not
discussed this year?
And act appropriately.
The content of the midterm
will be all the lectures,
all the topics up through
today-- hidden Markov models.
And I'll do a little bit
more on hidden Markov models
on Thursday.
That part could be on the exam,
but the next major topic-- RNA
secondary structure--
will not be on the exam.
It'll be on a p-set
in the future.
Any questions about the midterm?
And the TAs will be doing
some review stuff in sections
this week.
OK, thank you.
See you on Thursday.